i do think that this goes back to
afghanistan
and the weakness that was showed
by literally having
a president of the united states appear
to be proud that he got 90 out and the
world you know held their breath and
were shocked and they looked at each
other and were like did he just say that
we left 10 behind and he's proud of it
everybody saw that
um you know you again i why is
secretary of state anthony blanken still
in his job he has failed miserably so
many times
and yet he still has a job i don't
understand that
i just want to back up for one second
on the russia ukraine stuff when you
hear from
some of your counterparts that are
probably still in some of these
ambassadorships and and still overseas
are are people quietly saying to you boy
we sure do wish that orange guy was
still around because this wouldn't have
happened because it seems fairly obvious
to me that this would not be happening
if trump was president
absolutely it's across the board
all around i'll even go a little bit
further i'm getting
messages every single day from foreign
service officers at the state department
who are saying what a terrible mess we
have they're not happy with blinken uh
they see this as weakness um i mean this
is a real problem and and they see it
and these are people that i know
personally
did not vote for for president trump
because i have great relationships with
them and they've told me and we've
sparred about this before
but i respect so many foreign service
officers
uh in their work because they most of
them can salute the president and and
implement the policies of the president
even when they don't like the president
and so they can separate that um i
actually always found it refreshing to
have these political discussions with
people because the ones who were really
honest about yeah i'm a democrat and i i
think this way um it was much better
because uh you could trust them actually
you could see their work
and you knew they were implementing and
so i i have great friends who voted for
biden who are foreign service officers
and i love talking to them and it makes
a healthy environment but
many of them are admitting to me that
they uh they can't believe that this is
happening
so i had nikki haley on last weekend and
she said something similar and she also
said something that you sort of
referenced earlier about that the world
wants america to lead it really
desperately does it loves to hate on
america in a way but also really wants
america to lead i sense that's really
what you think too that it's like if
it's not us
everybody just runs around like a
chicken without a head
yeah i mean look i think that for china
or china yeah you look you look at the
middle east you look at now europe um
and i would even put
the latin and south america in this
category
there's an open admittance that
under trump everything was better
they're just they're literally able to
say that now
uh more than a whisper
and
they're right
they are right indeed i thought you were
giving me a long pause for uh
a crushing line there
they're right i mean what else can you
say you know so what do you think
yeah what do you think trump would be
doing right now i mean or or what would
he have done for the two weeks before
where biden was basically coaching putin
in what do you think trump would have
done then and now
so i hate this question and i and i the
reason why is is because you know now we
sit here and we have to answer the
question of now what would you do
between a terrible and a really terrible
choice
um look if i were in charge if that's
the the hypothetical right if you were
in charge what would you do if i was in
charge um we kicked joe biden out of the
white house because really what happened
was is biden led us down a terrible road
we got to turn around and go back
and fix this
but
i'm pissed off that we have to be
answering these questions of
you know now what are your choices
between terrible and really terrible if
donald trump had been in charge all
along we wouldn't be in this process uh
that we are now to to have a choice
between bad and really bad
um i do think that this goes back to
afghanistan
and the weakness that was showed
by literally having
uh a president of the united states
appear to be proud that he got 90 out
and the world you know held their breath
and were shocked and they looked at each
other and were like did he just say that
we left 10 behind and he's proud of it
everybody saw that
um you know
again why is
secretary of state anthony blanken still
in his job he has failed miserably so
many times
and yet he still has a job i don't
understand that
well i think it's because the media runs
cover basically what you were saying
before about new york times washington
post and everything else so what do we
do about that i mean okay so you drain
the swamp you start doing things let's
say trump's magically president again
and and you do the things that the
agencies you're talking about there's
still this media issue that that runs
cover yeah but you gotta you gotta
ignore your mistakes you gotta just
ignore them i mean they all have pay
walls so don't pay it and then you won't
read it and um the reality is is that
with social media you can educate the
public about what the government is
doing and be transparent that's the goal
the goal is to get information
transparent information honest
information to the american public we
have developed the system of a filter
that the media think that now they are
in charge of information to the american
people social media upended that just
like you know our phones having uh our
bank accounts on it we don't have to go
in and see the teller anymore we get to
go straight to our account and we get to
transfer money and control it
it's not unlike the media and that's why
i think they're clamping down on getting
trump off social media
they don't want to see a debate they
want to control it so they're applauding
it
it's it's terrible for this country it's
why first and second generation
americans are the loudest
pro-republican pro-trump group because
they left fascism they left
totalitarianism they know what it's like
and they see the signs with the media
some of the proudest members of the
america first crowd are first and second
generation americans you want to know
who the problem is in this country
seventh eighth generation white liberals
who haven't traveled enough
they don't understand how great america
is i'd like to have them travel a little
bit more and and then they will stop
tearing our country down and realize
that we're the greatest country in the
history of the world
yeah wait can you go a little further on
this sort of second generation like the
we're now seeing a huge explosion in
conservative latinos that's one trump
made major inroads in the in the black
community it's a little unclear where
that sits now at the moment um but can
you talk about that because that seems
to me to be the the future of this thing
not because of the color of their skin
or even their ethnicity but because of
the value stuff yeah well look i don't
even think that it's just the the
hispanics and latinos anymore um you
know certainly we know the stories of of
cubans who have left totalitarianism and
fascism and they become this rabid
supporter of freedom but it's in miami
man
come visit me you'll see it
i have a joke about miami which i can't
say because they'll hold against me
forever but it's a very funny one i'll
tell you personally um i love miami and
i love south florida because it's so
filled with people who are freedom
fighters and if you've ever had a taste
of not freedom
you want freedom
and so i think what's happening too is
eastern europeans chinese-americans
taiwanese-americans people who have
lived on russian-americans i actually
have some friends in la who uh born and
raised in russia who live here they're
some of the most pro-trump
positive uh love america patriots that
you've ever seen because they are like
the canary in the coal mine for what's
happening in our society for
institutions that take away
our freedoms and and i think you've got
to listen to first and second generation
americans tell the story of why they
came to america if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell